you
loop
china
hello everyone everyone i want to
thank dina and i kents and partners
company for being here today .
this is the first time in my life when in moscow
and actually in russia a
guy in and it seems to me that this is a very
beautiful city a magnificent country and
thank you very much one kings of
partner for being here
right now i am working as a skating consultant
for language learning
consulting reader and  a
language learning consultant is not the same as
a foreign language teacher yes
less a
church a little bit people out and instead
of stitching on line what's the difference i don't
teach people language i teach people how
to learn show language but like you start by
talking about muscle  meds legends of
line members, I would like to start my
speech by talking about the most
common myths associated with the
study of foreign languages
and in the likeness of debts and become the
first thing that perhaps many of you have
said to yourself that I have no talent for
learning foreign languages
sponsors of the region, but if you  think about
it, you speak Russian, and
this is one of the difficult languages ​​​​and pronunciation and
speak this language as  its native
language here with salt and prices from yellow and
it is very natural for you to speak Russian
speakers 5 like wokkin
speak the language like we
walk like the fee like we
learn to type on a computer an
hour breaks bytes no we don't think  about
how to do it we learn to do it
practice i'm
like it
but to learn a foreign language you have
to make a conscious choice a conscious
decision that you want to do it
people give up which is dead ops 2 he is
ready
many people
quit learning a foreign language
because they start out
wrong  approach is to sing again
at home not at all because they have no
talent no inclination to learn a
foreign language
xml
and
because in the classroom at school
without learning the language they watch the
language
mind on apr 3 5 yes in general the meat is cut off
when we study  a foreign language we
make a conscious choice and it is our
conscious effort we do not have any
pure need to learn it  our
for and as i said earlier you than deduction
ale hop
we all learn to type white
if we want to learn to play the guitar
wish i were
spent on this asset but all this is the
result of training practice the
result of our spending time on
activities
state aid if you think about very
famous performers life
very famous athletes he is below or
musicians orpheus or outstanding people in
other areas his file out da da i
spent a lot of time jerry you will find
that they devote most of their lives
to training
like and in africa if you look at the
two countries